[Music]
but we're going to begin with a
terrifying outbreak of gun violence on
Memorial Day security cameras captured
families ducking for cover as shots rang
out along a beach in south Florida now
nine people were hurt including four
children one suspect is in custody but
another has not been found police are
still looking for this person now this
all happened in the city of Hollywood
that's north of Miami and Manuel
bojorkas is there Manny good morning to
you it's just another example of how
you're not safe anywhere what are we
learning today
Gail good morning to you the Memorial
Day holiday meant there were thousands
of people out and about along this
popular stretch of beach now it's a
crime scene
the packed Hollywood Beach broadwalk
turned into chaos on Memorial Day
sending beachgoers running for cover
after the sound of gunfire rang out I
heard the several gunshots seen a crowd
of people running through here and then
we're like three more shots down the
street four victims including a teenager
and then he's hearing gunshots
say the first 9-1-1 calls came in just
before 7 PM after reports of gunshots
that started as a fight between two
groups to have people and complete
Reckless disregard of the safety of of
the public and to have an altercation
with guns in a public setting with
thousands of people around them is
beyond Reckless she's more serious video
of the moments after the shooting
captured a chaotic scene of multiple
injured people lying on the sand as
First Responders tended to their wounds
nine people were transported to local
hospitals including several children the
youngest just one year old I saw a young
man was on the ground leading and they
were applying pressure to try to prevent
the bleeding also saw a lady that was
very upset
because I think she had a wound to our
league police say they have one person
of interest in custody but they are
still looking for another suspect it's
unfortunate when we have law-abiding
citizens come to our beach to enjoy the
day that gets disrupted by a group of
criminals who engage in this type of
violent activity
of those nine victims one was taken into
surgery the others are said to be in
stable condition police say they will
continue to have a heavy presence here
as they investigate Tony
all right Manny thank you very much